what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the unbelievable and frankly
inconceivable tragic twist that just
took place in black clover a major and I
mean major character in the black clover
story is seemingly dead I am honestly
shocked and I'm still kind of in denial
but the final pages of chapter 238 were
clear in what they wanted to convey the
certain death of a major black clover
character at least that's what Yuki
Tabata wants us to believe at this point
in time but is everything really the way
it seems or is Tabata trying to psych us
out he has definitely done it before
with another important character so
let's dive into it and see what we can
make of this truly shocking turn of
events if you enjoy the black cover
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime or please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications in case you don't know we
are now making all of our videos
available in audio format as podcasts if
that's something you'd be interested in
you can check us out on Spotify Apple
podcasts or wherever you get your
podcasts just search anime upper audio
or click the links in the description
finally this video will contain black
clover manga spoilers and I mean major
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned
as you may know I did not make a special
video on the previous chapter chapter
237 because I didn't think that it gave
me enough material for an entire video
however chapter 238 changed that in a
really big way so now I definitely have
a lot to talk about and some of it
honestly I don't even know how to talk
about it just seems too insane and
tragic but I'm gonna have to try anyway
back in Chapter 237 we saw you know
sweeping in to save several of
Golden Dawn comrades including Klaus and
L'Etoile from a spade Kingdom warrior
who uses mist magic combined of course
with demon magic even though the other
Golden Dawn members that were there
didn't seem to stand a chance against
the mist magic user you know was able to
use his wind magic to blow away the mist
and then together with Klaus and
L'Etoile you know succeeds in defeating
the mist magic user and it is clear that
all three of them have gotten much
stronger after the time skip and it's
clear that their teamwork skills have
also improved dramatically however at
the very end of chapter 237 you know
Klaus and L'Etoile come face to face
with Zenon who's incredible bone magic
has taken over the entire battlefield
and who appears to have an injured
William Vaughn gence
at his mercy all of this sets up an epic
showdown between Zenon and the remaining
Golden Dawn members including you know
but I don't think that any of us were
expecting what happened next
Klaus and L'Etoile are stunned by the
condition of their Captain William
audience and you know seems to recognize
right away that Zenon is the leader of
this attack and a member of the dark
triad the same trio who killed his
parents and took the Spade Kingdom
throne by force Zenon notes that the
other two Spade Kingdom Warriors whose
names were apparently God that wah and
Poe Yala were defeated and he says that
it is because they are at 40% he also
says that it looks like there is no
point in bringing warriors here if they
can't go up to 50%
I assume that this percentage refers to
how much of a demon's power the warrior
is able to access and so the higher the
percentage the stronger the Warriors
power must be sylph warns you know to
use spirit dive right away because she
can immediately tell just how truly
dangerous Zenon is and so spirit dive
you know and a newly powered up Klaus
and let while try to take on Zenon
together but he is just too strong there
are no gaps in his
buon magic for them to attack through
and soon after the battle begins they
realized that the gap in power between
dem and xenon is just too damn wide
xenon is too strong at full power you
know succeeds in cutting through some of
the bones with his sword but he soon
realizes that his comrades Klaus and
L'Etoile were not capable of doing the
same Udo sees that both of them are
impaled on Xenon's bone magic with
multiple entrance and exit wounds some
of which look like they might have
punctured vital organs for all intents
and purposes Klaus and L'Etoile appear
to be dead
that was my first WTF moment in this
chapter but trust me it was not the last
also this is serious and sad guys so I
don't want to hear anyone making jokes
down in the comments about Klaus and
L'Etoile getting boned by xenon ok
moving on you know is heartbroken and
furious after seeing what happened to
his comrades
Captain William Klaus L'Etoile and all
of his other Golden Dawn friends have
been either killed or seriously injured
by xenon and his forces what's more as
the new vice captain you know feels
responsible for the safety of his
comrades so this is truly a disaster for
him you know can't take it anymore and
he rushes right at xenon his sword
clashing with Xenon's incredibly
powerful bone magic but it turns out
that not even the spirit of Zephyr sword
can cut through Xenon's bone magic
because xenon is able to regenerate his
bone magic faster than you know can cut
it and in case you're wondering yes
throughout this fight I kept thinking
back to unlimited blade works and Archer
saying I am the bone
anyway xenon acknowledges that you knows
power is zero tear the most powerful
tear possible so he decides to give you
know a glimpse of his true demon power
he raises the percentage of the demons
power that he is accessing to 55% and
with that xenon undergoes a physical
transformation he grows two long horns
on his head one black and one white and
he tells you know that it isn't that he
is weak or
but xenon is just that strong and he is
doing all of this for the glory of the
Spade Kingdom the chapter then jumps to
Ralph the man who had revealed the truth
about you knows royal origins Ralph
arrives to find the Golden Dawn
headquarters in ruins and whatsmore on
top of the ruins he finds Yunos body
pierced with what looks like a sword
although it could be potentially one of
Xenon's bones you know is lying
motionless on the ground his eyes open
but blank and blood dripping from his
mouth as self kneels on his chest crying
Wow just freakin Wow if it wasn't bad
enough that William L'Etoile and Klaus
all looked either dead or on the brink
of death but now the end of the chapter
is leading us to believe that you know
himself might actually be dead if that
were the case if you know really did
just die that would completely change
the black lower story into something
totally different and far more mature
the emotional and psychological impact
that something like you knows death
would have an hasta is unfathomable and
we know that if he ever did really lose
his rival and childhood best friends so
suddenly
hasta would never be the same again we
know that black clover was definitely
inspired by berserk and the death of you
know and the entire Golden Dawn squad
would absolutely bring this series
closer to Berzerk than it has ever been
however having said that I doubt that
you know is really dead as much as
Tabata wants us to believe that he might
be aside from the fact that you know is
such a major character and such an
important influence on hasta we also
just finally got you knows true
backstory and so much time was put into
the development of yoonho's character so
I really can't see him just dying now
out of nowhere
finally let's face it Tabata has
definitely psyched us out in the past
about the deaths of major characters we
all know what happened with Julius and
Julius was a far less important
character to the overall story than you
know I could definitely see Klaus willya
and other members of the Golden Dawn
squad potentially dying for real but you
know I don't think that's possible
considering that we have resurrection
magic forbidden magic necromancy magic
time magic and all of these other
methods that could potentially be used
to revive you know even if he did really
die I just don't see you know staying
dead after all the soul of Licht son is
still inside of you know so perhaps this
important fact will play into you knows
ability to actually survive this brutal
defeat at the hands of xenon please let
me know what you guys think
is it possible than you know might
really be dead and if he is what will
happen next in the story or do you
believe that he will survive but maybe
with some serious injuries or will he be
resurrected after really dying please
give me your thoughts down in the
comments below this turn of events was
just too crazy for me to handle on my
own I need some digital comforting and
therapy down in the comments by the way
aside from all the craziness with you
know and the other members of the Golden
Dawn squad apparently dying
how about xenon how freakin strong is
this guy and what has this brief battle
revealed about the true nature of his
demonic power
apparently the Spade Kingdom Warriors
who are able to use demonic power can
only access a certain percentage of the
demons power so the two Spade Kingdom
soldiers that you know managed to defeat
were only able to access 40% but xenon
is able to access at least 55% if not
more and this puts him at a level that
even post time skip you know cannot even
get close to
if xenon can access more than 55% then
we can only imagine how strong he is
at full power but here's what I'm
wondering is every single Spade Kingdom
warrior who can access demonic power
accessing the power of a separate demon
kind of like hasta has a specific demon
inside his grimoire on whose power he is
able to draw or are all of these
Warriors getting their power from a
single demon and that demon is Meggie
Kula if we're talking about a single
demon then I would assume that Magee
Kulas special ability is being
able to suck up the mana of the Spade
population and then redistributed to
those members of the Spade Kingdom that
he trusts the most
just like Asta's demon has anti magic
and the kotodama demon has word magic
McGee Kula must have the ability to
absorb the magic of others and also give
some of his own power to multiple
individuals of his choosing but it is
also possible that McGee Kula is not the
only demon present inside the Spade
kingdom it is possible that there are
multiple demons inside the kingdom and
McGee Kula is just one of them perhaps
he's the leader or perhaps he's just a
random demon one of many if that were
the case then every one of these Spade
Warriors who use demon magic might have
a unique demon at their disposal
so basically Spade could be a kingdom
with dozens of hasta level mages at
their disposal which would be an
absolute disaster for the clover and
Hart kingdoms we will have to wait and
see but the way that Zenon was able to
absolutely wreck the Golden Dawn squad
including the newly powered up you know
after the time-skip is absolutely
terrifying
if Zenon can get even stronger or if
some of the others Spade Kingdom
Warriors are even close to his level
we may see many more tragic deaths of
characters that we love and respect
before this massive war arc is over
I am so conflicted about this chapter
because on the one hand I loved learning
more about Xenon's demon power and I
loved seeing his magic in action but on
the other hand I hated seeing Klaus left
wall and even you know getting brutally
beaten and perhaps even killed by Zenon
let me know how strong you think that
Zenon might be at his full power and
does anyone stand a chance of defeating
this guy are there multiple demons
within this paid Kingdom or is it just
mcgee Kula please let me know what you
think down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video you want to see more
black clover content right here on the
channel please leave a like it
definitely helps and if you happen to be
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can now
listen to our videos in podcast format
just click the link in the description
or look for anime upper audio on Spotify
Apple podcasts or wherever you get your
podcasts I want to give a big thank you
to all of our anime opera patrons who
support our content and make these
videos possible first up let me thank
our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
Ingrid ah a Lola nada makoto-kun the
world Steelers the school bus and Tyson
Queenie no I also can't forget our
awesome pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings ell dress very
dolla beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's ki on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney emperor otaku Timothy a
vodkas Jean d'Arc and Joe Stanton if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us Binks Cowboys
[Music]